to protect the security of our fellow
citizens
the national emergency that the statutes
of directive 10 289 shall remain in
effect all copyrights shall be
transferred to the federal government
all wages and other forms of income are
hereby frozen
it's all happening so fast I won't be a
slave
you say you and henry rearden found it
a device harvesting limitless energy
without fossil fuels we're so close to
having something they won't be able to
fight they will try like hell to stop it
miss Taggart I think everyone agrees
that capitalism doesn't work you don't
understand the power they have the
government takes what they want and
taxes what they leave behind one of
these days you're gonna have to decide
what side you're on it's obvious the
drastic measures have to be taken
if you saw an atlas knees buckling arms
tremblingly still trying to hold up the
world with a less of a strength what
would you tell him to do where are they
anyone who could make a difference I'm
saying next door I've only got one thing
left worth reading this
if you feel you have the right to use
force against me bring guns time is
running out
who or what is john galt is he even a
man all right idea
are you ready